hello everyone and welcome to the pen
ultimate round of the US Chess
Championship it is Fabiano kwana with
the wi pieces versus abanu Mishra the
youngest Grand Master in the world who
is doing excellently uh in this um usj
championship fabi's in a fullo lead so
fab is on six and a half points and abim
Manu is on five and a half points so if
if abim Manu draws here uh he's still uh
I believe in contention for first place
but if he wins he has excellent chances
of actually winning the US Chess
Championship however uh should Faby win
this uh he will be crowned the US chess
champion a full round um before the
tournament finishes so let's check it
out it's quite a lovely game and also uh
some of you have been seeing those of
you who watch these videos with
headphones on that there is a buzzing
sound uh I don't know I I really can't
hear it but um as I I'm not using
headphones but I I've tried everything
to fix that so if you have headphones
you know just comment if the buzzing
sound is now gone uh so let's check it
out Fabby has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 abanu goes for the
Sicilian Defense Pawn to C5 Knight F3 D6
and Bishop to B5 with check going for D
medino rosimo attack uh Bishop to D7 and
now usually you capture or sometimes
Pawn to A4 is played Fabi go Pawn to C4
and okay we have Knight to F6 uh you
could double white pawns here captures
captures but then this Pawn is actually
uh very good here it prevents the knight
from being developed let's say the C6
square and black doesn't really gain all
that much aside from doubling the pawns
and later on you might even um uh find
it useful to advance your your pawns on
the queen side so instead after the C4
Pawn push uh we have Knight to F6 Knight
to C3 and now G6 and only now that abim
Manu revealed his um plans for the dark
Square Bishop uh Fab goes for the trade
here even though it's not something that
you might um expect you'd probably
expect something like Pawn to D4 but Fab
goes for the trade we have captur
capturas and he castles King side we
have Bishop to G7 and now Pawn to D4 as
Fab is in the lead he is in uh well he
doesn't have to risk anything all too
much he can play a safe opening and then
even if he doesn't win this game he can
go uh very strongly in the in the last
round so see captur on D4 Queen captur
and D4 the position is still a known one
Knight captur on D4 is the move that is
usually played here Queen captures
Knight to C6 attacking the queen and
queen D3 so ending up with a sort of a
marozi bind structure here uh we have
castles and now Bishop to D2 the bishop
although you you could develop it to E3
to F4 to G5 uh Knight is coming to D5
and then of course your Bishop is coming
to C3 to counter um abanu strong Bishop
on G7 and there are some games that
reach this position Rook 8 to d8 it was
played in the game nvada versus Grand
Delio that ended in the draw and also E6
is a know move Jil Mard played it
against ATM bakro and he lost that game
but here we have Pon A6 by abanu and it
is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so let's check it
out uh Rook 8 to B1 is Fab's first new
move of the game of course he's
preparing Pawn to B4 we have Knight to
G4 now uh and here comes Queen to E2 uh
we have Rook F to C8 and now uh Knight
to D5 so uh Knight to D5 still waiting
with this Pawn to B4 push of course the
idea is Knight to B6 forking the two
Rooks and the queen so abanu needs to go
back with the queen and now Bishop to C3
at the counter ABI Manu is a very strong
dark Square Bishop on G7 and now Bishop
captures um on C3 and probably you'd
expect Knight captures on C3 why ruin
your Pawn structure why prevent white
from playing B4 uh but Fabby shows that
he's not interested in playing it safe
he actually will try to win this game
and he plays B captures on C3 introduces
a new imbalance in the in the position
now gives his Rook a semiopen B file and
he doesn't have to worry about moves
like Queen to A5 is C3 and A2 are now
nicely defended if for example after um
Bishop captures and C3 you go Knight
captures Queen to A5 is could be very
annoying uh now the A2 Pawn is attacked
also you moved your knight from this
very strong Square uh E6 is coming and
so on so by playing B captures Fabby
says Nope I I very much like my position
and I will put a knight on B6 at some
point especially if you just attack it
with E6 right away so in the game Rook a
to B8 uh and now Pawn to C5 getting rid
of the Double C Pawn or at least trying
to and preventing Pawn to B5 so here we
have Knight C to E5 and now Knight
captures on E5 we have Knight captures
and pawn to F4 by Fabby now the problem
is if you go Knight to C6 then Black's
pieces are uh
uh well they're just uh you you can't
move them for example if Knight to B6
attacks The Rook Rook C7 Rook F to D1 uh
your position is just terrible and
you're still going to have to um mess up
your Pawn structure after Fabby play C
captur on D6 and uh gets rid of his
Double T Pawn so instead abanu goes
Knight to D7 he says all right you can
capture here I'm going to get the the D
C file for my Rook at least that c
captures e captures and now Faby plays
Pawn on to F5 and here you already feel
the the weaknesses of the dark squares
surrounding the black king now you see
all sorts of Moves Like F6 Queen can
come to E3 then to H6 Checkmate the
black king The Rook might come to F3
then H3 then you go after the the king
um using the H file so uh this is not
not easy to play and especially if you
play something like B5 which is a move
you generally want to play You're just
out of time here so abanu goes Queen to
G5 uh the queen will be very useful in
stopping the attack against the black
king now Rook to F4 uh preparing Rook to
G4 uh we have Knight to E5 now stopping
that but now Rook B to F1 you could also
go capture on G6 right away Faby decides
to play Rook G to F1 uh B to F1 first
and now Rook to C5 this is how abanu
activates his pieces but now Queen to E3
and um the the threat is very clear for
example if you go B5 again it's a move
generally want to play Just F captures H
captures and Knight to F6 with check and
that's it King G7 you're going to play
H4 uh Queen has to move Queen to H6 now
Knight to D7 forking The Rook the rook
and the Knight as the famous meme goes
but of course the Knight cannot be
captured it doesn't matter if you
capture the Knight or you don't if you
don't then uh then white will capture on
E5 and then play Rook captures on F7
check and win the black queen or if you
capture the Knight it's same thing Rook
captures on F7 check moves the king away
from the queen you capture the queen and
then you Checkmate the black king so
that's the idea so abanu has to figure
out a way out of this he plays Rook to
f8 and now uh Fabby plays Queen to H3
you could go for some captures there are
other moves you could consider Queen to
H3 is by far the strongest because it it
introduces um a new threat that is after
Pawn to B5 again we will trade here
captures captures go Knight F6 check and
then after the king moves of course you
will deliver checkmate with Queen to H7
so there's really no way to handle this
other than to give up the exchange which
is what abim Manu does Rook captures on
D5 e captures and now he brings the Rook
into the game Rook to E8 Al mind you did
not become the youngest grandm in the
world by throwing in the you know the
towel at the first sign of trouble so F
captures and G6 F captures and now Queen
to E3 again with the threat of just um
Rook to f8 check picking up the queen so
abanu goes back and now Pawn to H3 now
Fab is up the exchange and he needs to
play some precise Moves In order to win
this King G7 uh Queen to D4 nicely
aligning with the King now again Rook to
F7 becomes a threat and Rook to E7
stopping that uh we have Rook to F6 uh
going for Rook to E6 and now Rook to D7
uh we have Queen to F4 tripling up uh
now preparing moves like Rook to f8 and
now Rook to C7 freeing up the D7 square
or in some lines you can even go Queen
to E7 for example if Rook to f8 you can
go Queen to E7 and F7 will be nicely
defended uh so Queen to B4 was played uh
here uh there are some maybe better
options than what Fabby went for with
Queen to B4 H4 uh is pretty much instant
resigns you cannot allow H5 and if you
stop it by playing H5 yourself then
Queen G5 comes threatening Rook captures
winning the queen here uh or uh if you
if you defend the queen then comes Rook
to E6 this is how you get your Rooks
into the game and now of course you you
have to trade captures captures the pawn
is hanging and after you defend it Rook
to F6 and with the D6 Pawn hanging and
the G6 Pawn hanging black is basically
without a move so this is how you can
wrap up the game nicely uh but of course
it requires a lot of calculation Faby
went for Queen to B4 he went after the
D6 Pawn but now ABI Manu nicely defends
it Knight to C4 and okay everything is
defended we have Rook six back to F2 by
Fabby and now Queen to G5 so a bit more
passive than the line that we've
discussed we have Queen to A4 now going
after black the black king and now Queen
to E3 stopping that while also being
just very annoying here and attacking
the C3 Pawn so Queen back to D1 and now
Queen captures on C3 grabbing a pawn
there Rook to F3 attacking the queen
queen D2 now offering a queen trade
because now if Fabby trades the Knight
captures Forks the two Rooks so of
course Fabby has to avoid this queen to
A1 check Knight to E five blocking and
now Rook to sorry not to E1 Rook to D1
going after the the black queen we have
Queen to C2 uh Rook to F2 and queen to
E4 Pawn to A4 by fabbi and now Pawn to
H5 so all of a sudden abanu is back in
the game he has a very strong Knight on
E5 The Rook has uh the C file for itself
not really all that many squares that he
can use but it's much better than the
position was let's say 5 10 or even 20
moves ago uh we have Pon a five grabbing
more space on the queen side and now
Queen to E3 we have Queen to B2 and now
Pawn to G5 I'll be mind you goes for for
the attack on on the black on the white
king H but now Queen to B6 Fabby finds
an attack on the rook and on the black
queen and now you really should trade
here uh there's uh no good way of um
avoiding this if you play something like
Queen to C3 then Queen captures on D6
and now your entire position falls apart
so here unfortunately for a mind you he
has to trade but okay he still has a
very strong Knight and Fabby will have
to play incredibly precise to win this
Rook C5 we have Rook to F5 going after
the pawn here so King G6 and now Rook D
to F1 going for a nice check here to win
the pawn so Rook captures on D5 but
Fabby says no problem I don't win this
Pawn I'm going to win the B7 Pawn so
Rook to f8 and now Pawn to G4 and now uh
very interestingly Fabby again shows how
strong he is he plays Rook to G8 check
you might expect something like Rook to
B8 right away but if you go for Rook to
B8 right away then you allow black sort
of a sort of initiative with G captures
G captures and Rook B5 Rook captures and
B7 then King G5 and already with the
King Knight and the Rook going so near
your your king uh you might give uh
black too many chances to actually find
some drawing resources so Rook to G8
check forces the black king away and
then only then you go after the pawn
here now it doesn't matter if you go
here of course Fab will throw in a nice
check if Rook H7 then Rook goes after
the pawn soby Manu goes after The Rook
right away and only now Rook to B8 so
the same thing will happen only the
black king will be much less active uh
Rook to B5 you have to uh put the Rook
behind the pass Pawn or rather soon to
be past Pawn Rook captures on B7 with
check King to G6 and now H captures on
G4 H captures and Rook to B8 preparing
to advance The Pawn King to G7 and now
King to H2 we have Rook to B3 cutting
off the white king uh Rook to C1 now of
course going for Rook to C7 check so
King to F6 we have Rook to C7 and Knight
to G6 stopping any checks from behind uh
we have Pawn to B7 and now G3 with check
now if you go down the board of course
you get checkmated so Fabby has to go
King H3 Knight to F4 check and now King
to G4 and now although it seems like you
can capture you really can't if you
capture here it's a matter of a simple
check and once the king moves of course
uh you just bring your queen into the
game and the black has nothing here of
course you have to capture and you have
too many moves before you even start
advancing that pawn and white has two
Rooks for your knight so instead after
King G4 Knight to E6 was played now
comes Rook sorry not E7 Rook to D7 going
after the pawn Knight to C5 there is no
way to stop this you might as well
captur it on B7 Rook captures on D6
check King to E5 Rook to C6 and now
unfortunately you cannot capture on
on B7 because if you capture with the
Rook then first a knight sish to Rook
captures on C5 King D6 Rook captures on
B7 and you end up being up a full Rook
or even if you capture with the Knight
it's not much better Rook captures on A6
now the Knight can't really move uh and
uh it's a well it's resigns time next of
course the Knight will get attacked and
then uh you will force a trade so after
Rook C6 Knight to D7 was played it's one
last uh try at maybe maybe holding Fabby
to a draw E5 really messes up but Rook
to E8 with check King to D5 and now Rook
captures on A6 Rook captures on B7 and
King captures on G3 so now it's two
Rooks against the rookie Knight but Hab
Fabi also has the pass G Pawn Rook to B3
with check of course King H4 preparing
to advance the pawn Knight to C5 and now
Rook to A5 uh now the Knight of course
cannot move King to D6 and now
interestingly Fabi of course uh can
calculate that Rook captures and G4 is
completely winning uh but even he does
not allow himself this opportunity to
even make a mistake possibly while
calculating so he advances the pawn uh
of course he will advance the pawn a
little bit further before he actually
decides to give up the exchange because
you will have to do it at some point the
Knight will just be very annoying uh
King to D7 attacks The Rook Rook to E1
we have Knight to B7 and now again Rook
to A7 King to C6 uh G5 and now King to
B6 attacking the rook and now is the
time that we discussed Rook captures and
B7 King captures Pawn to G6 King to C6
and now Pawn to G7 preparing to advance
the pawn to the to the final rank to
become a queen Rook to B8 and now King
to H5 and he was in this position on
move 75 that abanu Mishra resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so as Fabi went into the
penultimate round as the sole leader he
won this round which means that he's now
uh us Chess Championship of 2023 a full
run before the tournament actually
finishes which is absolutely incredible
but that is just how strong Fabby is so
we'll see what happens in the final
round if there will be some interesting
games but yeah Fabby did not need uh the
the full 11 rounds 10 was enough for him
uh so yeah here you resign for those of
you who like me to finish games is uh
well simply Rook G1 preparing to advance
the pawn to a queen black will block
this you will go go um near the pawn
black will try to help and after black
finally gets here yes you've defended
white cannot push the pawn but Rook F1
check forces the king away and then you
will of course gobble up The Rook move
your king Advance the pawn to become a
queen and Checkmate the black king uh so
yeah very nicely done by Fabby a very
nice line going after a very safe
approach and then just at some point
deciding that okay it's time to
completely outplay my opponent but
you've seen how one imprecision from
Fabby here uh where he could have gone
for this uh sorry let me just rewind
this uh where he could have gone
uh sorry
uh uh instead of Queen to B4 he just uh
you know should have played H4 and then
it's you know game over after Queen to
G5 but he gave abanu two slow moves
Queen B4 and Rook to F2 and abanu
immediately was back in the game and it
took many many more moves to to take him
down so you know if you if you give
someone a chance they will they will
take it they will find it and they will
uh even if you don't see it they will
find because they are looking for it
desperately so you know always always
try to play the the absolute best move
and try to always play the most uh
accurate move even if it means you know
spending a few more minutes finding a
move uh you know if you're a tournament
player you I'm sure you know exactly
what I mean by this uh so yeah once
again really hope you enjoyed it uh for
those of you who are interested in the
standings so these are the standings
Fabiano in so lead with seven and a half
out of 10 points followed by six points
Dominguez Perez and Wesley so abano
Mishra on five and a half in fourth
place Hans nean leevon Aran on five out
of 10 on four and a half out of 10
Samuel Sean and Ray Robson on four out
of 10 we have Andrew Tang Dario SCH Sam
shankland and Jeffrey Shong
so uh definitely quite a tournament uh
so yeah once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to danou and I would like to thank every
every favetto uh congratulations Dr she
Tucker Beckman and Eddie Indus for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day